all right now excuse me we're now
starting off the topic of geometry and
we're going to start with this very easy
accessible kind of two-sided result one
of which you should know in are quite
familiar with the other one maybe less
so okay so we're talking about angle
sums I should have said maybe of
polygons polygons are just straight
sided figures with many sides that's
what the poly means
okay so first subheading is interior
angles now one of the nice things about
the formula I'm about to show you the
result is that we could draw any polygon
and this would work that's going to be
the case continue but just for the sake
of illustration so we're all in the same
page let's all draw the same kind of
polygon what I'd like you to draw is an
irregular shape what does it mean when
something's irregular it's it's not
regular it's actually a perfect way to
ask like so then what does regular mean
if I tell you there's a regular
quadrilateral regular it normal is what
would mean in like English but it has a
very special meaning in mathematics what
does regular mean in mathematics okay so
if you if you can name it that's a
starter but actually regular means even
more specific than that don't draw this
but here's a regular quadrilateral here
is an irregular quadrilateral
he is an irregular quadrilateral here's
an irregular quadrilateral so what is it
that makes this regular it's that all
the sides are equal which then implies
also all of the angles are also any
unequal all the regular means is you
have different side lengths they just
don't all match okay so even a rectangle
is irregular and a pipe is irregular so
draw me something irregular and let's
make it a let's make it a hexagon can
you make me an irregular hexagons do
your best I hope your irregular hexagons
looks different to mine but what I want
to try and work out is the interior
angles the angles on the ends
all right what do they add up to that's
what the English some is okay now
there's a really lovely construction
that shows what the angle some is and it
doesn't matter what shape you drew
here's what I want us to do we know it's
a classic mathematical strategy where
you're something weird and complicated
to try and boil it down to something
that you're familiar with okay what I
want you to do is take two corners of
your of your hexagon that are separated
by one corner see that so I'm picking
these two because there's one in between
what I want you different there is can
you join those two like so if you've got
another color do that because that'll be
handy
now once you've joined that up once you
join that up I want you to join up
another pair of vertices we're going to
go with this one and let's go over here
down in the corner you can see I'm still
following the same rule see how there's
on this one corner in between okay so
you can see what I've done there in this
case I've got one more to go I'm gonna
divide up into okay so what you should
have created is three intervals and all
from the same corner that you started
with that one there okay and what we're
gonna do is notice that we've created
what shapes inside our hexagon we've
created triangles how many four and um
let's just give them names shall we
let's call this a B C and E now because
we've got four triangles in here do you
notice that the angle sum of the whole
shape the angle sum of the whole shape
includes all of the angles in every
single one of the triangles watch see I
see this angle over here see you all in
there to create that angle which is an
awkward weird shape you need to have
these two yeah and they add together how
about say this angle this angle over
here do you see that to make up that
angle it's got one two three four pieces
in
each of which is an England one of the
triangles does that make sense so I can
say the overall angle some in fact
that's what we can write underneath the
overall angle some equals the sum of all
the triangle angle sums that's a bit
awkward sum of triangle angle sums it's
like a palindrome kind of okay now how
many triangles did we count again four
of them and we know that every triangle
no matter what kind of weird shape it is
has the same angle sum every time it's
180 so this is the over overall angle
sum of a hexagon and it seems like four
times 180 720 720 okay now beside this
and this bits a bit different we all
just drew a hexagon but beside this one
I want you to draw is any polygon you
like I'm not going to tell you how many
sides okay and I want you to repeat the
same exercise for your own sake don't
put too many sides and then put two for
you because then it's boring okay what I
want you do is draw a polygon any
polygon and divide it up into triangles
just like we did here what I want you to
find out for your shape is how many
triangles can you fit inside your
polygon can you do that use your ruler
draw something find out how many
now yeah interesting
okay have you noticed the pattern say no
one notice a pattern who drew a Pentagon
today oh and draw a pentagon yep how
many triangles can you fit in your
Pentagon three and what's interesting is
you can divide it up in all kinds of
different ways like for example you can
go from here and draw a couple of sides
down or you could go from here and draw
a couple of sides across three triangles
every time right three triangles so that
would make the angle some three times
180 which is 540 did anyone draw a shape
which was sharp
like this had pointy bits to it yes okay
what how many sides did Jose have Allen
five okay so you also did a Pentagon how
many triangles each finger still three
and you can see I've got a quadrilateral
even though this what we call the non
convex polygon it's got weird angular
bits watch this same deal I can always
divide up into triangles and even though
this angle here this one here that's
really large what I call this start with
an R it's called a reflex angle this is
very large but these ones are very small
to almost compensate right two triangles
six sides four triangles five sides
three triangles for sides two triangles
what's the relationship between the
number of sides and the number of
triangles always minus two so therefore
let's write a formula that encapsulates
this therefore just as an example what
we've shown okay the angle sum of an
n-sided so we're saying you know what
just as I asked you all to draw whatever
number of sides you like let's just say
in any number an n-sided polygon equals
okay you always said it was two less
right six sides four triangles so two
less than n is n take away two and
that's the number of triangles you can
fit so what do you multiply that by
BAM put a big box around that please
that is an important result